[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
defense attorneys for millionaire real
estate air robert durst request a
mistrial due to his failing health
having mr durst go through this trial is
a serious
risk to his health and even his life we
need to stop this
the fireworks in the courtroom as
friends of susan berman testify
she revealed information about the
disappearance of his missing wife
and the list of requests made by defense
attorneys for the doomsday mom before
lori balodebel is moved to a mental
health facility
plus the deadly argument over a mask at
a georgia supermarket
the 30 year old veteran officer wounded
after returning fire
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome to law on crime daily i'm brian
buckmeyer along with terry austin
the trial will go on that's the word
from the judge in robert durst trial
as lawyers for the real estate era says
his health is deteriorating
angela levy is here with the argument
and testimony about what the victim
might have revealed
brian robert durst attorneys have
repeatedly asked for a mitch trial they
say that his
health is failing and he seriously
cannot assist with his own defense
but it's not the first time that a dying
defendant has stood trial
susan harmon and susan berman knew one
another since they were children
harmon told the jurors about a call she
received from berman
in the early 1980s what could you tell
from tones of voice
uncharacteristically confiding in me
like just i gotta tell her to tell you
this
harmon revealed what berman said she
said that
her friend bobby had had a fight with
his wife
she didn't know what she was going to do
if there was something she said i don't
know what i'm going to do and i was like
even what you're going to do it had a
fight there was an accident on the
stairs
and that she had to do something she
recalled the decades-old call
shortly after attorneys argued about
durst's medical condition
he sat in a wheelchair in jail clothes
unable to dress himself
wearing a catheter for a urinary tract
infection
and sepsis a blood infection his lawyers
say he has end-stage renal
disease and needs dialysis the admitting
doctor
at la county
usc hospital described him as an
ill-appearing
cachectic male cochectic means a
dying person but deputy district
attorney john lewin argued against
further delay
saying durst has planned to feign
dementia and use kovid to get a mistrial
getting catheterized is no fun i myself
had a catheter
for an entire week going in and out of
court it was not pleasant
i in fact recognize had the same size
one mr durst has which was under my
clothes
judge mark windham again denied the
request for a mistrial
mr durst is a human being i am a human
being
i am not callous it is not easy for me
to require him to endure
any pain windham cited california case
law the trial court is not
obligated to suspend criminal
proceedings rather the proceedings are
to be conducted in a manner that
reasonably accommodates the special
needs of the accused
so how sick does a defendant have to be
to delay a trial
we looked into it and trials for war
crimes involving nazi guards have moved
forward
with the accused brought into court on a
stretcher
in one case a defendant had an iv during
a trial
attorney nafis syed said a trial can
move forward despite a defendant's
advance to age and illness
we saw this time and time again in the
war crimes tribunal particularly because
many of these war criminals
were in hiding for decades and by the
time the court was able to
to find them they were older many of
them had
suffered from various illnesses and they
used that time and time again to delay
the trial
for now durst trial will go on with
witnesses testifying that susan berman
confided in them years before she died
about helping robert durst cover up
kathy durst's murder
she once told me that she called albert
einstein
medical center for him
and said she was kathy
now that woman was named linda opps she
was a very good friend of susan berman
and durst lawyers questioned
why it took her so long to come forward
with this information
then prosecutors called other witnesses
including opp's lawyer to back up her
claims
brian thanks ange joining us today is
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman and terry austin
julie durst seems mentally there but by
the looks of it he looks like he's
almost on death's door
what do you think about continuing this
case with his current condition
look you know he certainly does look
like he's on death's door at the same
time i think we
could all agree that he still seems to
be participating in this
um in his defense he's writing notes to
his attorneys
when the judge asks about his catheter
he's the one lifting up his catheter to
show
that it's there so the issue is whether
or not he's able to engage
with his attorneys and actively assist
in the representation
the problem i have is if he's in pain if
he's in some way out of it at one point
someone said that he was sleeping at the
table
that is not someone who is assisting
their defense that is not someone who's
engaged
and i do wonder what is the point in
time when we take a break and say you
know what his medical needs need to come
first
even though potentially he's committed
these horrible crimes he's still
presumed innocent the question begins as
where do we do what do we do with
individuals in this state
uh terry loyal manipulative and perhaps
in love with durst are berman's friends
painting her
as the perfect accomplice to durst
crimes or just a really good friend
well look there's no question that she's
a really good friend of robert durst
but i wouldn't call her an accomplice
necessarily look if in fact
she made this phone call to albert
einstein medical center
pretending to be kathy durst i would
label her an accessory after the fact i
mean for that all you have to do is show
that
someone assisted and it was after the
crime and
they had knowledge that the person
committed the crime and they were
intending to help the person avoid
arrest so we could call her
that i suppose and we certainly have
heard
multiple witnesses talk about the fact
that this call was made susan berman
felt guilty
about that so maybe she was an
accomplice after the fact
absolutely and jeanette julie touched on
him just a bit but what's durst's
demeanor been like in court since he's
been treated for the latest illness
you know uh it did appear at one point
during the latest arguments over his
medical condition
that um he was engaged in listening to
that and then at another point during
testimony it did appear
that he possibly nodded off that he had
fallen asleep and his attorney david
chestnut went over and spoke with him
and then after that he turned around and
and very wide-eyed
looked at the jury and was kind of
sizing the jury up so
he appeared conscious and alert it's
whether or not you know everything else
going on is
impacting his ability to help with his
defense yeah seems alert at points but
not
consistently through the trial i think
that's the question that julie was
really trying to hit the nail on the
head there
thank you everyone for your
participation still ahead on law and
crime daily
jury selection is underway after nearly
a decade of waiting for justice for the
family of a murdered 13 year old boy
but first laurie vallo daybell to be
moved to a mental health facility
after being indicted in the murders of
her two children the lengthy requests
made by the doomsday mom's attorney
[Music]
next
welcome back attorneys for the so-called
doomsday mom are sending a long list of
demands to the court
now that laurie valo dabal is officially
declared incompetent to stand trial
attorney mark means is claiming in court
documents that lori valo dabel is in a
fragile mental state of incompetency
as a direct result of the historical and
systematic mental
emotional and physical abuse she
suffered lori along with her husband
chad dabel are facing murder charges in
connection with the deaths
of her two children jj valo and tyler
ryan
and the death of chad's first wife tammy
chad is pleading not guilty
while laurie's case is on hold for now
means was requesting
all conversations about lori's treatment
including apparent talks between the
idaho department of health directors and
prosecutors
he's also asking the judge for private
and confidential access to his client
in addition means is requesting to be
directly involved in her treatment
for the names and credentials of all
people involved in her care
and the medication and proposed plans
laurie is scheduled to receive mental
health care for the next 90 days
if she's deemed competent after that
time proceedings against her will resume
if not her time in the facility will be
extended for 180 days
back with us as criminal defense
attorney julie reynoldman and terry
austin
terry this is a lengthy list of demands
from the attorney
uh is he able to even ask for these yet
alone get them
well you know medical information is as
personal and confidential as it gets and
in fact you have to have an
authorization under hipaa to get that
type of information
it could be he wants to know the
medications because he wants to
determine
how the trial is going to proceed when
it does
proceed after she's deemed competent at
some point
but if he's asking for this information
to make
medical decisions he has to get a proxy
to do that
some sort of medical proxy so that he
has the right to make those decisions
and you know at this point those
types of proxies are usually just for
family members
but really in my opinion he may be the
closest person to her
right now and if he does get the medical
proxy and an authorization i think
he's going to have to make sure he makes
decisions
in her best interest and lori may be
able to give that those
permission to him julie break down
what's going to happen
to lori valo now and will any of this be
heard in front of the jury
so it's a great question so you know
she's been found
unable to go forward with regards to
assisting in her defense and the job
basically is to get her to be
competent can they give whether it be
drugs or any type of assistance therapy
that allows her to be healthy enough
to proceed to trial now the question
really is there's a separate issue
whether or not they're going to use any
of that in her defense now as we know
that state i believe it's idaho does not
allow for an insanity defense
however it does allow um for
any type of mental health issues to
potentially negate her intent
and so there's so many questions the
first question is well if she becomes
mentally healthy
is she perhaps gonna at this point
cooperate against
uh chad davao that's that's always a
possibility and the second issue is if
she's not is she going to use this
mental health
issue to somehow mitigate her behavior
with regards to the crimes of which
she's charged
interesting possibilities they're
definitely excited to see how that plays
out
in the next 90 or 180 days based on her
mental health status
jury selection continues in colorado for
the father accused of murdering his son
during a court-ordered visit
thirteen-year-old dylan redwine went
missing over the thanksgiving holiday in
2012.
in 2017 a grand jury indicted mark
redwine for second-degree murder
and child abuse resulting in death
according to court documents dylan
reportedly found compromising photos of
his father
including him wearing women's clothing
and eating feces from a diaper he was
wearing
opening statements are expected on
monday june 21st
coming up on law and crime daily how an
argument over wearing a mask in a
grocery store apparently led to a deadly
shooting
plus the disturbing case of two sisters
raped at a daycare center
and the strong words from the judge at
sentencing the
powerful reminder to all next
[Music]
we're back a judge in ohio sentenced an
elderly daycare worker to 22 years in
prison for raping two young girls
law and crying founder and host of the a
e series court camp
dan abrams has the emotional victim
impact statements
our next stop is inside franklin county
common police court in columbus ohio
for the sentencing in the disturbing
case against 70 year old terry mcfadden
you will be a tier 3 registrant for your
lifetime with in-person verification
every 90 days
two months earlier mcfadden who worked
at a residential
daycare business run by his wife pled
guilty to two counts of rape
the victims were attendees of the
daycare two young sisters
only four and six years old at the time
terry mcfadden is a psychopath who raped
our girls
fooled us fooled 25 years worth of
families
and his wife's day care he's a skilled
pedophile and a sociopath
after an emotionally charged statement
from the girl's mother that had mcfadden
shaking his head judge julie lynch also
gives him an opportunity to speak
prior to sentencing i apologize to the
victims
to two little girls i hope to
become a to to work to become a better
person
and when i
when i had served my complete sentence
but mcfadden's apology
falls on deaf ears this court is so sick
and tired of seeing adults
ruin and abuse children
these are literally just
one step from being babies
they come to a daycare those parents
struggle
so that when they release their children
to someone during the day
they have some semblance that that child
is going to be protected and safe
not let alone two of their children
being raped by your own admission sir
for sexual gratification
you violated a four-year-old and a
six-year-old i do not know at this time
what the total ramifications will be for
those two young children
but there isn't anybody who doesn't
understand now the developmental phases
of children take place from zero to six
years old
you can't even know what damages you've
done
for sexual gratification
this to me is so mind-boggling that you
used and abused two little children like
they're they're
they're inconsequential
beings those are human persons with
human dignity
i'm gonna tell you something mr mcfadden
there's no free rapes in my courtroom
and with that the judge sentences
mcfadden
on count one i'm sending you to prison
for 11 years
on count four i'm sending you to prison
for 11 years they will be consecutive to
each other for a total of
22 years the horrifying case comes to an
end
but before dismissing the court judge
lynch issues one
last powerful reminder to all
folks if you see it you smell it you
know it's happening you report it
and this ends in this courtroom that'll
be all
powerful statements by the judge when we
come back why two teens are now behind
bars for a mass shooting in austin texas
the chaotic scene and the officers who
rushed in to help
[Music]
next
welcome back an off-duty deputy is
recovering in georgia
after a triple shooting over wearing a
mask in a georgia store
left a cashier dead and the deputy and
suspect injured
the georgia bureau of investigation says
30-year-old victor lee tucker jr
was checking out of the store monday
afternoon tucker is accused of getting
into an argument about his mask with a
female cashier
officials say tucker left without paying
then immediately returned
according to reports tucker pulled out a
handgun and shot the cashier
the dekalb county sheriff department
says an off-duty veteran police officer
was in the store and returned fire
not sure exactly
[Music]
julie the investigation is still ongoing
but an alleged murder over a mask
is this a senseless shooting or could
there be something more
i'm guessing there's nothing more look i
mean both of us you know handle homicide
cases
i did for 15 years people got killed
because they gave someone the wrong look
so it doesn't take much sometimes
for someone to react the way they did
now there seems to be some
indication although we'll know we'll
know in the future that he potentially
had some mental health issues
which just goes back to the issue if you
put a gun in the hand of someone who has
mental health issues
something tragic is going to happen but
it'll be interesting to see what the
additional evidence is
that explains why this this this
horrible
incident occurred absolutely we'll
continue to watch that case
as facts develop over time thank you
now to florida where two officers are
being credited for their quick thinking
for rescuing a special needs child from
a canal
police in palm beach gardens received a
call friday morning of a 12-year-old
running towards a lake
when they arrived the boy was in
distress in the canal police say the
child was treading water but began to
struggle
without hesitation the officers made
their way into the water
body cam video captured the officers
saving the boy from possibly drowning
and in texas two suspects are under
arrest for a mass shooting that killed
one person
and injured 13 others in downtown austin
police say a 17-year-old was taken into
custody at a high school
along with another minor the
seven-year-old is being charged as an
adult
shots rang out early saturday morning on
june 12th investigators are canvassing
to determine
how many bullets were fired and are
looking for video and photos of the
shooting
the austin police chief says the
incident appears to be isolated
and most of the victims were innocent
bystanders
as ems made their way through the large
crowds
officers did not want to delay care and
they actually began
carrying victims from the immediate
crime scene and in some cases
they transported those victims in their
police vehicles
so not to delay that care it was clear
as people were running out of that
seeing our officers running in
terry now because of the suspects ages
there are some things we know and some
things we don't
can you explain well one of the suspects
is 17 so that one will be tried as an
adult but the other one is
under 17 and so anyone under the age of
17 their records are not subject to
the public and what the state is trying
to do
here is not to criminalize juvenile
misconduct they want to try to promote
rehabilitation of the child so they're
not making those records
public they're trying to make sure that
the individual
has an opportunity to do better in life
and not have a record
against them ultimately though ryan the
d.a is going to decide
whether or not this individual who's
under 17 should be tried as an adult or
a child
interesting to see how that plays out
and what the ada decides terry and julie
thank you very much and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you